[Music]
[Applause]
how do you explain when things don't go
as we assume or better
how do you explain
when others are able to achieve things
that seem to defy all of the assumptions
for example
why is apple so innovative
year after year after year after year
they're more innovative than all their
competition
and yet they're just a computer company
they're just like everyone else they
have the same access to the same talent
the same agencies the same consultants
the same media
then why is it that they seem to have
something different
why is it that martin luther king
led the civil rights movement
he wasn't the only man
who suffered in a pre-civil rights
america
and he certainly wasn't the only great
orator of the day why him
and why is it
that the wright brothers were able to
figure out controlled powered manned
flight when there were certainly other
teams who were better qualified better
funded
and they didn't achieve
powered man flight the wright brothers
beat them to it
there's something else at play here
about three and a half years ago
i made a discovery
and this discovery profoundly changed my
view
on how i thought the world worked and it
even profoundly changed the way in which
i operate in it
as it turns out
there's a pattern as it turns out all
the great and inspiring leaders and
organizations in the world whether it's
apple or martin luther king or the
wright brothers they all think act and
communicate the exact same way
and it's the complete opposite
to everyone else
all i did was codify it
and it's probably the world's simplest
idea
i call it the golden circle
why how what
this little idea explains why some
organizations and some leaders are able
to inspire where others aren't let me
define the terms really quickly every
single person every single organization
on the planet knows what they do 100
some know how they do it whether you
call it your differentiating value
proposition or your proprietary process
or your usp but very very few people or
organizations
know why they do what they do
and by why i don't mean to make a profit
that's a result it's always a result by
why i mean what's your purpose what's
your cause what's your belief
why does your organization exist
why do you get out of bed in the morning
and why should anyone care
well as a result the way we think the
way we act the way we communicate is
from the outside in it's obvious we go
from the clearest thing to the fuzziest
thing
but the inspired leaders and the inspire
or inspired organizations
regardless of their size regardless of
their industry
all think act and communicate from the
inside
out let me give you an example i use
apple because they're easy to understand
and everybody gets it
if apple were like everyone else
a marketing message from them might
sound like this
we make great computers
they're beautifully designed simple to
use and user friendly
want to buy one
and that's how most of us communicate
that's how most marketing is done that's
how most sales done and that's how most
of us communicate into personally we say
what we do we say how we're different or
how we better and we expect some sort of
behavior or purchase a vote something
like that here's our new law firm
we have the best lawyers with the
biggest clients we have you know we
always perform for our clients do
business with us here's our new car it
gets great gas mileage it has you know
leather seats by our car but it's
uninspiring here's how apple actually
communicates
everything we do
we believe
in challenging the status quo we believe
in thinking differently
the way we challenge the status quo is
by making our products beautifully
designed simple to use and user friendly
we just happen to make great computers
want to buy one totally different right
you're ready to buy a computer from me
all i did was reverse the order of the
information what it proves to us is that
people don't buy what you do people buy
why you do it people don't buy what you
do they buy why you do it this explains
why every single person in this room
is perfectly comfortable buying a
computer from apple
but we're also perfectly comfortable
buying an mp3 player from apple or a
phone from apple or a dvr from apple but
as i said before apple's just a computer
company there's nothing that
distinguishes them structurally from any
of their competitors their competitors
are all equally qualified to make all of
these products in fact they tried a few
years ago gateway came out with flat
screen tvs
they're eminently qualified to make flat
screen tvs they've been making flat
screen monitors for years
nobody bought one
dell came out with mp3 players and pdas
and they make great quality products and
they can make perfectly well designed
products
and nobody bought one
in fact talking about it now we can't
even imagine buying an mp3 player from
dell why would you buy an mp3 player
from a computer company but we do it
every day people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it the goal is not
to do business with anybody with
everybody who needs what you have
the goal is to do business with people
who believe what you believe
here's the best part
none of what i'm telling you is my
opinion
it's all grounded in the tenets of
biology not psychology
biology
if you look at a cross section of the
human brain looking from the top down
what you see is the human brain is
actually broken into three major
components that correlate perfectly with
the golden circle
our newest brain our homo sapien brain
our neocortex
corresponds with the what level the
neocortex is responsible for all of our
rational and analytical thought and
language
the middle two sections make up our
limbic brains and our limbic brains are
responsible for all of our feelings like
trust
and loyalty
it's also responsible for all human
behavior all decision making and it has
no capacity for language
in other words when we communicate from
the outside in yes people can understand
vast amounts of complicated information
like features and benefits and facts and
figures it just doesn't drive behavior
when we communicate from the inside out
we're talking directly to the part of
the brain
that controls behavior and then we allow
people to rationalize it with the
tangible things we say and do this is
where gut decisions come from
you know sometimes you can give somebody
all the facts and your figures and they
say i know what all the facts and
details say but it just doesn't feel
right why would we use that verb it
doesn't feel right because the part of
the brain that controls decision making
doesn't control language and the best we
can muster up is i don't know it just
doesn't feel right or sometimes you say
you're leading with your heart or you're
leading with your soul well i hate to
break it to you those aren't other body
parts controlling your behavior it's all
happening here in your limbic brain the
part of the brain that controls decision
making and not language
but if you don't know why you do what
you do
and people
respond to why you do what you do then
how will anybody how will you ever get
people to to to vote for you or buy
something from you or more importantly
be loyal
and want to be a part of what it is what
you that you do
again the goal is not just to sell
people who need what you have the goals
to sell to people who believe what you
believe
the goal is not just to hire people who
need a job it's to hire people who
believe what you believe
i always say that you know this
if you if you if you um
hire people just because they can do a
job they'll work for your money but if
you hire people who believe what you
believe they work for you with blood and
sweat and tears and nowhere nowhere else
is there a better example of this than
with the wright brothers
most people don't know about samuel
pierpont langley and back in the early
20th century the pursuit of powered man
flight was like the dot-com of the day
everybody was trying it
and samuel pierpont langley had what we
assume
to be the recipe for success
i mean even now you asked people why did
your product or why did your company
fail and people always give you the perm
same permutation of the same three
things
under capitalized the wrong people bad
market conditions it's always the same
three things so let's explore that
samuel pierpont langley
was given fifty thousand dollars by the
war department to figure out this flying
machine money was no problem
he held a seat at harvard and worked at
the smithsonian and was extremely well
connected he knew all the big minds of
the day
he hired the best minds money could find
and the market conditions were fantastic
the new york times followed him around
everywhere and everyone was rooting for
langley
and how come we've never heard of samuel
pierpont langley
a few hundred miles away in dayton ohio
orville and wilbur wright
they had none
of what we consider to be the recipe for
success they had no money they paid for
their dream with the proceeds from their
bicycle shop not a single person on the
wright brothers team had a college
education not even orville or wilbur and
the new york times followed them around
nowhere
the difference was orville and wilbur
were driven by a cause by a purpose by a
belief they believed that if they could
figure out this flying machine
it'll change the course of the world
samuel pierpont langley was different he
wanted to be rich and he wanted to be
famous he was in pursuit of the result
he was in pursuit of the riches and lo
and behold look what happened the people
who believed
in the wright brothers dream worked with
them for with blood and sweat and tears
the others just worked for the paycheck
and they tell stories of how every time
the wright brothers went out they would
have to take five sets of parts because
that's how many times they would crash
before they came in for supper
and eventually on
december 17th 1903
the wright brothers took flight
and no one was there to even experience
it we found out about it a few days
later
and further proof that langley was
motivated by the wrong thing
the day the wright brothers took flight
he quit
he could have said that's an amazing
discovery guys and i will improve upon
your technology
but he didn't he wasn't first he didn't
get rich he didn't get famous
so he quit
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and if you talk about what
you believe you will attract those who
believe what you believe
well why is it important to attract
those who believe what you believe
something called the law of diffusion of
innovation and if you don't know the law
you definitely know the terminology the
first
two and a half percent of our population
are our innovators
the next 13 and a half percent of our
population are our early adopters
the next 34 are your early majority your
late majority and your laggards
the only reason these people buy touch
tone phones is because you can't buy
rotary phones anymore
[Music]
we all sit at various places at various
times on the scale but what the law of
diffusion of innovation tells us
is that if you want mass market success
or mass-market acceptance of an idea
you cannot have it until you achieve
this tipping point between 15 and 18
market penetration and then the system
tips
and i love asking businesses what's your
conversion on new business and they love
to tell you oh it's about 10 proudly
well you can trip over 10 of the
customers we all have about 10 who just
get it that's how we describe them right
that's like that gut feeling oh they
just get it the problem is how do you
find the ones that just get it before
you're doing business with them versus
the ones who don't get it
so it's this here this little gap
that you have to close as jeffrey moore
calls it
crossing the chasm because you see the
early majority will not try something
until someone else
has tried it first
and these guys the innovators and the
early adopters they're comfortable
making those gut decisions they're more
comfortable making those intuitive
decisions that are driven by what they
believe about the world
and not just what product is available
these are the people who stood online
for six hours to buy an iphone when they
first came out when you could have just
walked into the store the next week and
bought one off the shelf these are the
people who spent forty thousand dollars
on flat screen tvs when they first came
out even though the technology was
substandard
and by the way they didn't do it because
the technology was so great
they did it for themselves
it's because they wanted to be first
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
proves what you believe
in fact people will do the things that
prove what they believe
the reason that person bought the iphone
on the first in the first
six hours or stood in line for six hours
was because what they believed about the
world and how they wanted everybody to
see them they were first
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it so let me give you a
famous example a famous failure and a
famous success of the law of diffusion
of innovation
first the famous failure
it's a commercial example
as we said before a second ago the
recipe for success is money and the
right people in the right market
conditions right you should have success
then
look at tivo
from the time tevo came out about eight
or nine years ago to this current day
they are the single highest quality
product on the market hands down there
is no dispute
they were extremely well funded market
conditions were fantastic i mean we use
tivo as a verb i tivo stuff on my piece
of junk time warner dvr all the time
but tivo's a commercial failure
they've never made money
and when they went ipo their stock was
at about 30 or 40 and then plummeted and
it's never traded above 10. in fact i
don't think it's even traded above six
except for a couple of little spikes
because you see when tivo launched their
product they told us all what they had
they said we have a product that pauses
live tv
skips commercials
rewinds live tv and memorizes your
viewing habits without you even asking
the cynical majority said
we don't believe you
we don't need it
we don't like it you're scaring us
what if they had said if you're the kind
of person
who likes to have total control over
every aspect of your life
boy do we have a product for you
it pauses live tv skips commercials
memorizes your viewing habits etc etc
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
serves as the proof
of what you believe
now let me give you a successful example
of the law of diffusion of innovation
in the summer of 1963
250 000 people showed up on the mall in
washington to hear dr king speak
they sent out no invitations
and there was no website to check the
date
how do you do that
well dr king wasn't the only man in
america who was the who was a great
orator he wasn't the only man america
who suffered in a pre-civil rights
america in fact some of his ideas were
bad
but he had a gift
he didn't go around telling people what
needed to change in america you know he
went around and told people what he
believed i believe i believe i believe
he told people and people who believed
what he believed took his cause and they
made it their own and they told people
and some of those people
created structures to get the word out
to even more people
and lo and behold
250 000 people showed up on the right
day on the right time to hear him speak
how many of them showed up for him
zero
they showed up for themselves
it's what they believed about america
that got them to travel on a bus for
eight hours to stand in the sun in
washington for in the middle of august
it's what they believed and it wasn't
about black versus white 25 of the
audience was white
dr king believed that there are two
types of laws in this world those that
are made by a higher authority authority
and those that are made by man and not
until all the laws that are made by man
are consistent with the laws that are
made by the higher authority will we
live in a just world
it just so happens that the civil rights
movement was the perfect thing to help
him bring his cause to life we followed
not him not for him but for ourselves
and by the way he gave the i have a
dream speech not the i have a plan
speech
[Music]
listen to politicians now with a
comprehensive 12-point plans and not
inspiring anybody
because there are leaders and there are
those who lead
leaders hold a position of power or
authority but those who lead
inspire
us whether they're individuals or
organizations we follow those who lead
not because we have to
but because we want to
we follow those who lead not for them
but for ourselves
and it's those who start with why
that have the ability
to inspire those around them
or find others who inspire them
thank you very much
[Music]
oh
sharing
that's video on the human network
cisco
welcome to the human network